mr. president thank you very much for
speaking to our tea at this difficult
time for your country difficult period
which is what my first question is about
your recent absence during the towel
volcano eruption and people have been
worried there has been widespread
concern about that absence and about
your health
are you still fit to be President you
know
please stood up believe media especially
the ruptor that's the mouthpiece of the
CIA and the US I was there before they
made the announcement that they did not
go on I was there two days earlier then
I went home to devolve to rest when I
came back last night I went directly
again to the evacuation areas so do not
believe that kind of what garbage are
being dished out by rap layer which is
an American CIA funded news agency and
which has been well they have not paid
their taxes and they we are questioning
them because media must be 100% owned by
the country Philippines
now we found out there are a lot of for
one it's owned by the Americans and so
it does violate the Constitution which
says that media or the press should be
owned by 100% Filipinos
well well while you were there when you
went back to the volcano you promised to
appear on the volcano and to eat its
ashes is that part of a new government
policy perhaps a war on volcanoes
well that this one that is one aspect of
life which we cannot really fight in the
sense that when Mother Nature blows it
blows and we just have to take the
necessary steps to counter it the child
to meet the challenges of the arc
ash fall and the devastation that it
will create on the livelihood the
people's would lost a livelihood and
home well as you say you know there's
it's never easy every new day brings
brings a new challenges one of your
latest challenges is that you gotta
taste the US sanctions for the alleged
mistreatment of an opposition
politicians my question is have you
learned the lesson that Trump was trying
to teach you
it should be the u.s. who should learn
the lesson from us
because they think that you are a
backward country that we are inevitable
times that we are incapable of
dispensing justice we have survived in
1946 were declared Republic but before
that we fought the Americans and their
occupation you see the opposition and
the Communists got together to invent
these about secretary de Lima receiving
money by way of campaign contributions
from the drug lords in this country and
the Americans simply do not believe that
the Secretary of Justice it's incapable
of receiving money to finance all things
to ensure the victory and they wrote on
the issue that it was a trumped-up
charges by the opposition the yellow the
Liberals
and by the Communists and so they
started to believe in the lies of the
opposite side we cannot do anything some
says that right not does a trumpet the
United States is that one of the
sanctions would be where they would not
allow the entry of any official
connected with the prosecution of
Kothari de Lima I countered that if you
do that then I will allow I will not
allow Americans to enter into the
Philippines without a visa they should
get it get a visa from our ambassador as
of now they come and enter as if the
only place so I can't do that if you do
that then you start to have to present
as a visa before you enter the country
one of the staples of your presidency
has been a u-turn in in foreign policy
you've been making a lot of other
friends but for example with Russia with
with China my question is what can rush
in China offer you the Philippines that
America can't nothing except that you
respect the sovereignty because America
continues to look us as a vassal state
because when we were under the Americans
for 50 years and the live of the fat of
the land before we got our independence
we went to war against them so if you do
not if I cannot get a credible posture
from the Americans I can get it from the
Russian and the the Chinese the China
Chinese government it's because they
respect the sovereignty of the country
which America is totally totally lacking
it's not only the Philippines but
Salvador they do not respect sovereignty
through government well in recent years
you've pointedly been shopping for
example Russian weapons yeah most
recently the joint Indian Russian cruise
missile yes
but you never got your credit card out
you never did the question is why what
are you waiting for
we had the
with our priorities I was buying for 12
cargo helicopters and you know we are
not a rich country however you program
the the funds of government how to
budget it it's always this always not
enough to go around to it so I'm sure
that we will have to make the down
payments and be prompt in our you know
just because Russia is a friend doesn't
find out that we do not you know we we
we abscond or we do not pay your debts
so it's still money and really we're not
that rich but we have placed the orders
now 12 milli cut military helicopters
cargo choppers how far do you think
trade and cooperation friendship between
Russia and the Philippines can
realistically go after rule there is
eight thousand kilometers separating
Moscow and Manila what do you want from
this relationship is it nuclear and
mining or something else I am sure
Russia could come here and look for
viable businesses that can help Russia
your country and we we do not consider
the distances a limit in our friendship
in our desire to be a a partner of
Russia and the rest of the Eastern
countries in in trade and commerce we do
not think that the distances
it's on the minus side it's a plus side
and nothing can really be hindrance if
you really want to do it with another
country
well what one country that's been
getting very close to the Philippines is
is China physically it has been getting
very close because unlike say for
example Vietnam which has been very
vocal in its opposition to China's South
China she claims you and the Philippines
they haven't been as vocal in their
opposition why is that because you know
the other said really wants to do a more
aggressive stance and I cannot afford to
do it I cannot afford a stunt where I
would be dropping my drumming my drums
because we cannot afford it it would
annihilate the Philippines and so that
is a very dangerous spot the island is
near our Islands our provincial islands
the local government of the Philippines
is new you know near them and so it
would be a reckless move if I sent out
just like Vietnam small vessels only to
get the bloody nose at the end of the
day the response might not be that
contain if I get to move because of the
so many American ships here they might
just also want to take advantage and
make a pretext that they are defending
the Philippines and it will flow out
beyond our control
and I said the war
with China at this time it's of no use
to us we wait as well just be friendly
do some improve our trade and commerce
and let time heal it's it's I'd rather
tomorrow will take care of itself one
thing for sure and like any other
historical claim the world is always
changing and we did not really do it at
the expense of their lives of Filipinos
well speaking of changing times you've
been president now you enter into your
fourth year honestly how would you raise
yourself how would you rate what you
have done because your war on drugs has
divided the world
what are your do tell techno mix as they
call them have divided economists will
you be remembered as someone who solve
problems or someone who created problems
well no need to remember me in the
future but let me say it here and now
that drugs can't destroy uncontrolled
drugs in a country will destroy and I've
told everybody that if you destroy him a
country like the Philippines with drugs
I will kill you there's no quarrel
border I will kill you and what
economics is I am viewing towards so
many I'm I'd like to open you friends
with Russia we do to China helping in
Korea increase in trade and commerce
it's robust and maybe if I could start
trading with Russia
could be good it would be not fine I
mean America is not the Philippines and
it really means is not America it ain't
that way anymore and I refuse to
dovetail under American foreign policy
they were always at they were always
antagonizing the Chinese and so soda
soda the Philippines I just received an
invitation to go to the United States
where there were ten leaders habit I was
invited by Obama will you know
now didn't you say you wanted to make
friends eh
yeah but you know one time when I was
being criticized by Obama any press
conference now he should have realized
that I was also head of sovereign but he
should have criticized me in the proper
venue so the bird dropped the case to be
United Nations rather than castigate a
president of another country on a press
con so I got mad so but I would never do
it to Tom because this very nice person
actually Trump is a nice person
it's just style of doing things what Tom
does not I do not believe that he really
wants to work alone
hehe maybe he wants to teach some
leaders also how can the Philippines
stay on the path that you said without
you without your passion and without you
unique stuff
frankly I cannot answer the question and
I cannot even I was going to succeed me
it would greatly depend on the people
now either in the opposition or with me
in my administration to really think
hard about it but if we are improving
economically if we have reduce crime to
47% we have lower the drug-related
crimes here it would mean a lot
III would gladly say that no country can
progress without law and order no
country no city that is in my experience
last if if I may why do you think people
have allowed you to do and
hey what you have done and said why is
it that you know sometimes you've done
things that they don't want and yet
still they support you well because
people are used to you know human beings
are animals of habit when it's being
done and done and done repeatedly done
it's kind of a it comes to them
naturally and almost a second nature but
when they see things when they see good
things arising from a little discipline
if the same improvement or the things
which were allowed what are prohibited
people should realize them it is in my
generation it is during my time that I
should be doing things to protect to
make them easy
I fight to worse and I want to end it
now and I want to end communism I want
to end drug problems or at least reduce
them to the barest minimum so that the
next generation will not have so many
problems of all tell me if it's wrong to
be passionately defending your country
against drugs especially now that it has
come in from the bumboat trial trial the
triad the bomb betrayer and sin yellow
size also coming in with cocaine there
has never been a say there's always been
a short of supply but now it is an
abundant only to only come from Mexico
and the trial trial the trial triad
consists there in somewhere in China
China
well it is not the policy of China China
also executes people but we are not as
rich as China we don't have the most
sophisticated gadgets we cannot afford
the high-priced drug while authorities
grip means that can tell you if you age
what drives what what motivates men that
are older increasingly to go into
politics at 70 at 80 because politics is
difficult it's a fight it takes a lot of
energy every day it's a it's a daily war
what motivates you to get up in the
morning I have not realized that ever
taken it all though but I do my work
just the same as earlier when I first
entered politics in 1988 I was elected
mayor of the city of Davao then for the
succeeding years I never lost an
election until the presidency it started
in 1988 as mayor then as a congressman
Dennis a vice mayor to my daughter to
skip the provision of a successive
fourth term it's only good for three
then I allowed me I asked my daughter to
run as mayor I ran for vice mayor then
resumed my mayorship again until I never
realized I never D counted the years
that I was in politics I was there just
to work and work and work since 1988 and
aren't you getting tired yes a bit I
would say physically this always a
diminution in the many hours you can
stay awake and
the number of days you are out in the
field inspecting Public Works and
visiting military camps and all and
going to difference especially during
the Morales age I was there almost ten
times I flew in there stayed until the
midnight and a few of so those were the
things that I said maybe the stress
added to be when you say born worry when
you are really wary of doing things and
I said because aside from the fact that
we have to stay late and you have to
travel and then there's this tremendous
stress of lying where the bullets were
whizzing around and I got the whole in
on the helicopter in one of the
helicopters as they rode president
you've you've been like always very
candid and straightforward one more time
thank you very much
it's my pleasure